[Music]
they kind of have their own story some
of them have been there so much longer
than then we have been there and will be
there you know outlive all of us
okay say trees
you lose that sense of time and you're
suddenly surrounded by all these new
smells and these sounds of the birds and
the sounds of you know those branches
when they they creak it just it's like a
whole
amazing thing for the senses that's kind
of what i'm trying i'm trying to get
that feeling of
sometimes you know the mystery of it
[Music]
whenever i walk into a kind of woods i
always feel that i'm entering into a
different pattern of time or something
it's like the way light is chopped up by
the leaves
it feels like the moment itself is kind
of chopped up a little bit and lots of
different moments are almost held within
the envelope of
that little forest
in quite a magical way
it's actually quite hard to envisage an
environment without trees and and their
habitats and what what they mean and how
they how they behave it's a rich
creative world
and i can't think that anybody's life is
worse off for having trees in it part of
improving it for wildlife is increasing
number of trees because trees do quite
useful things don't know anyone's got
any ideas what trees do handle
well we as muslims believe we are
custodians caretakers of the earth so
we're hoping that by planting a tree we
will benefit the earth and it will
preserve it for future generations
if a muslim plants a tree and a bird an
animal or a child benefits from it then
it will be classed as a charitable act
and it's it's an act that doesn't stop
it can carry on even till the hereafter
i suppose i connect trees with
memory really and with
with time
and um maybe even learning learning
about time
you know a is for apple
a is for acorn
maybe there's some dim connection in my
head between
trees and
alphabets and
books and learning
i'm particularly interested in the
relationship between people and trees
i mean i i know probably a few hundred
of the trees in this plantation
personally
i've revisit the same tree and think how
are you today i want to know how you're
you know are you springtime yet are you
i want to know when the tree first
produces its its first flowers i mean
it's like a farmer having lambs it's
that same thrill of seeing new life
isn't it
i have to try and get this right because
it's a really good quote by nature
still nature is the fountain's head the
source from whence all must originally
spring and should an artist continue his
practice without referring to nature he
must soon form a manner and that's what
i was finding was happening with my work
i was like actually my work is becoming
incredibly mannered and so i went into
the middle of the rainforest and did a
residency in the jungle and kind of
didn't intend on it becoming the you
know the whole rest of my practice well
not forever but up until now and just
fell in love with these landscapes and i
came home and after being in this place
where my eyes were completely opened to
like you know the twists of the branches
and the curls and the leaves and when i
was looking at my own landscape and all
these woodlands around me it was like i
was looking at them for the first time
and so it kind of continued this
inspiration that you know i had to had
to paint them
it was monday bank holiday near the end
of may rough middle of the day year and
of the country if the country is england
oak apple or oak and nettle day axis of
my year thinly plotted as my tree the
far end of our thinning garden in a
border shape to waiver like a child's
drawing of sea
it's clock-handed why where the trunk
parted ways a first rung that even just
turned seven i stepped onto into the
above
this wobbly earth above earth
wordlessly i knew then i'd later be gone
like possibly my treehouse from that
border and my attention divided thinly
as the light
or is that time through the green grey
space i was sitting in as i reached up
for a branch
or is it balance
or vantage on this tentative level
a story
how did it feel to plant a tree
something to be proud of yeah
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video